[Music]  real arson presented kc applet with the  Best Actor Award the Oscars but did not  clap as he came on page to accept and  people took notice  Vanity Fair after about it at the Consul  Island premiere where she said quote I  think that whatever it was that I did on  stage kind of spoke for his self on  background Casey Affleck softer Winn was  met with controversy due to to sexual  harassment lawsuits against him from  2010 that gained renewed focus around  the success of Manchester by the sea  these claims were denied by Affleck and  both suits were settled real are San  Juan best actors the previous year for  portraying a sexual abuse victim in room  she used her platform to raise awareness  and at last year's Oscar she greeted and  hugged as sexual assault survivors who  joined Lady gaga on stage for the  performance of her song till it happens  to you